Have you ever stopped to think what poverty really is?
Poverty is more than a lack of resources.
It implies malnutrition, a lack of access to education and basic services,...
...discrimination, thousands of issues.
Our world reveals chilling statistics.
For instance, one in every four children under the age of five,..
...still don't reach the adequate height for their age.
There are many people who still live in extreme poverty,...
...meaning they survive on very little money a day.
We have a goal at our fingertips and you can make it possible...
...to completely eradicate extreme poverty by 2030.
We want to ensure all men and women have equal rights...
...to access basic services.
We want to call upon development cooperation...
...to promote policies and projects geared towards eradicating poverty.
Let's do this.
You can make it possible.